[Musik]
in einer weit weit entfernten galaxis
auf einem kleinen blauen planeten gibt
es eine spezies die seit jahrzehnten
fieberhaft etwas sucht sie starren
endlos lange in den sternenhimmel bauen
gigantische maschinen und widmen
teilweise ihr ganzes leben dieser einen
suche
doch selbst die klügsten unter ihnen
konnten die lösung die große antwort
noch nicht finden die eine formel die
die grundlage unseres universums
beschreibt die weltformel keiner
doch vielleicht einmal ein unbeugsamer
physiker
[Musik]
das entscheidende ist ja für die physik
das ist die theorie auf nachprüfbare
vorhersage machen haben wir haben meine
stücke compete ferry auf universe meint
aufgabe bevor wir zur mächtigsten formel
des universums kommen möchte ich einmal
unserem sponsor danken der dieses video
hier überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat
und zwar nord vpn jpn erlaubt euch das
internet so anzusteuern als würdet ihr
in 60 ländern überall auf der welt
gleichzeitig sein und das macht es
möglich events zu gucken an die wir hier
in deutschland eigentlich gar nicht
rankommen
die formel 1 zum beispiel kann man hier
in deutschland ja leider nicht mehr im
freetv gucken aber mit nord bpm kann ich
alle rennen einfach über servustv aus
österreich schauen nur natürlich ohne
dafür nach österreich fahren zu müssen
denn das ist mit nord pm nur einen klick
entfernt und was filme angeht könnt ihr
euch auch so absolute klassiker wie der
pate pulp fiction oder auch alle herr
der ringe bequem per netflix aus kanada
anschauen
und das beste ist mit dem kot doktor
watson bekommt ihr einen monat gratis
wenn euch ein zwei jahres paket holt
falls sie jetzt noch nicht überzeugt
seid dann habt ihr immer noch 30 tage
zeit als sich anders zu überlegen und
euer geld zurückzubekommen jpn punkte /
doktor watson oder einfach beim checkout
doktor watson we can no gemeint ob dort
das dachte stephen hawking wird
passieren wenn wir sie finden die
weltformel eine formel die beschreibt
auf welchen physikalischen gesetzen
unser gesamtes universum aufbaut
denn bisher passen unsere beiden großen
theorien nicht zusammen die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie und die
quantentheorie widersprechen sich eine
von beiden ist also wahrscheinlich
falsch oder wir wenden sie zumindest
falsch an
aber was liegt unserer welt dann
zugrunde
um die 1000 forscherinnen und forscher
weltweit philosophieren experimentieren
und rechnen seit jahrzehnten in
unterschiedlichsten projekten um eine
lösung zu finden
und einer von ihnen will nun einen weg
gefunden haben wie wir die weltformel
finden könnten
er heißt stephen wolfram ist physiker
und erfinder der berühmten matte
software mathematica und der website
wolfram alpha die wahrscheinlich einige
von euch kennen werden
und obwohl er viele jahre nicht mehr in
der physik unterwegs war hat er nun
verkündet dass er schaffen könnte woran
andere seit jahrzehnten scheitern aber
kann das stimmen
im letzten jahrhundert gab es schon so
einige anwärter für die weltformel
supersymmetrie extra dimensionen
quantengravitation und die stringtheorie
doch sie alle waren nicht erfolgreich
denn damit eine theorie in der physik
etabliert werden kann muss sie sich in
verschiedenen experimenten und
beobachtungen immer wieder als richtig
erweisen
vor allem aber muss sie die welt noch
besser erklären als die bisherigen
theorien in unserem fall also besser als
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie und
die quantentheorie die messlatte für die
neue weltformel liegt also ziemlich hoch
wir haben mit professor hermann nikolei
vom max planck institut für
gravitationsphysik gesprochen und ihn
gefragt woran es aktuell bei der suche
noch hakt wir vermuten dass völlig neue
begriffliche einzig benötigt werden und
wir wissen eben nicht was die sehen hier
also wir haben das richtige
instrumentarium diese theorie glaubt zu
beschreiben dass möglicherweise noch
nicht fahren
die mathematik die man dafür benötigt
die können ja auch eine ganz anders sein
wow das klingt unglaublich faszinierend
und gleichzeitig ziemlich unmöglich
aber das ist es nicht tatsächlich hat es
so einen durchbruch schon mehrere male
gegeben
quantenphysik er setzte unsere
klassische betrachtung des universums
und das standardmodell wiederum ersetzte
die frühe version der quantentheorie
einsteins allgemeine relativitätstheorie
ersetzte die newtonsche
gravitationstheorie und ja es gab mal
eine physik vor einstein überrascht mich
auch immer wieder was brauchen wir also
um noch mal so einen durchbruch zu
schaffen
ich kriege ja viele zuschriften von
menschen die meinen sinn gefunden zu
haben
aber es gibt es konnte ein häufig aus
einer ecke wo weil sich irgendwas
zusammen fantasiert fast alle dieser
versuche die scheitern schon daran dass
er in irgendeinem sehen dem widerspruch
zu dem stehen was mehr als richtig
erkannt haben für die forschung der
weltformel muss man also eine gründliche
kenntnis der bekannten physik mitbringen
ebenso eine gründliche kenntnis der
mathematik sowie physik gebraucht wurde
und dann aber zusätzlich noch in reichen
fantasie um erstens die mathematik zu
verallgemeinern aber statt
physikalischen sei eben auch nicht neue
begriffe auszudenken die dann uns
weiterbringen können genau einstein zum
beispiel den haben am anfang auch alle
für verrückt gehalten was die zeit soll
relativ sein was für ein quatsch
die meisten physiker kamen nicht einmal
auf die idee die absolut zeit in frage
zu stellen
doch einstein hat es gewagt und heraus
kam eine der berühmtesten theorien der
physik doch schon 1918 wie es ein stein
selber darauf hin dass seine theorie
noch nicht vollständig sein kann und
derzeit gibt es zwei verschiedene
hypothesen was für eine entdeckung hier
die lösung bieten könnte
und natürlich auch stephen wolfram idee
zu der kommen aber gleich noch eine
möglichkeit wäre dass man neue
elementarteilchen entdeckt von der sorte
von teilchen die man jetzt versucht hat
amtsjahren zu nachzuweisen
sie waren also nicht da das heißt dass
wir die theorie aber es gibt auch andere
sorten von teilchen und insbesondere
weiß man bis heute nicht was die so
genannte dunkle materie besteht
das ist also eines der großen im offenen
rätsel der physik ein vielversprechender
kandidat für die weltformel ist die
stringtheorie sie hat das problem aber
vorläufig eigentlich nur größer gemacht
sie kann zwar die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie und die quantenwelt
vereinen spuckt dafür dann aber ganz
viele parallel universen aus eine andere
theorie die uns weiterhelfen würde wäre
eine theorie der quantengravitation wie
verhält sich die gravitation bei
geringen abständen zum beispiel zwischen
zwei quanten bisher konnte man das noch
nicht herausfinden und die hoffnung ist
mit hilfe des informations paradoxon
schwarzer löcher erklären zu können
scheint sich auch erst mal leider
erledigt zu haben mehr dazu findet
übrigens in diesem video hier was so ein
bisschen der inoffizielle erste teil zu
dem video hier gerade ist aber es
überhaupt kein problem die reihenfolge
zwischen den beiden users egal also
guckt euch das einfach danach an und
auch den large hadron collider im cern
den großen teilchenbeschleuniger in der
schweiz und frankreich hatten viele als
großen hoffnungsträger gesehen
doch die super symmetrischen teilchen
die man besucht hat hat man nicht
gefunden
der theoretische ansatz den man dafür 30
40 jahre lang verfolgt hat hat leider in
die irre geführt
die suche nach der weltformel ist im
moment etwas in der luft es gibt einige
ansätze dafür moment kann man eigentlich
nur die mathematische konsistenz
untersuchen das solchen theorie aber das
entscheidende ist ja für die physik dass
die theorie auch nachprüfbare
vorhersagen macht die schönste theorie
nützt überhaupt nichts wenn sie nicht
irgendwann durch das experiment oder die
beobachtung validiert wird
okay das ist der status quo der
forschung und jetzt behauptet stephen
wolfram dass er einen weg zur welt vorne
gefunden haben will
er ist physiker hat mit 20 schon seinen
doktor gemacht und ist ein langjähriges
mitglied an der princeton university
school of applied science an der auch
ein stein gewirkt hat vor einigen
jahrzehnten verließ wolfram die
wissenschaft und gründete die firma
wolfram research die forschungsprogramme
und suchmaschinen entwickelt hat sein
neuestes projekt heißt wolfram physics
und damit will er nun die physik
revolutionieren und die weltformel
finden
und wie sie das machen das finde ich
persönlich mega faszinierend denn es ist
ein komplett anderer ansatz die idee ist
dass die computer verwenden um ganz
viele verschiedene universen zu
simulieren mal mit solchen gesetzen
regeln und konstanten und mal mit
solchen und dann suchen sie nicht nach
der weltformel sondern sie suchen in
diesen ganzen universen nach unserem
universum irgendwann so hoffen sie ist
eines der vielen simulierten universen
die sie vom computer erhalten haben
zufällig unser universum und der
algorithmus der zu diesem universum
geführt hat der kann dann in die
weltformel übersetzt werden
das ist zumindest die idee man muss
allerdings dafür einige annahmen und
vereinfachungen machen
im geteilten sieht das so aus die
universen werden von einem computer als
grafik dargestellt
anfangs bestehen sie nur aus punkten in
einem raum dann wird eine regel also ein
algorithmus quasi angewandt der neue
punkte generiert diese regel kann alles
mögliche sein
wichtig ist nur dass sie genau bestimmt
wie der graf sich entwickelt ziemlich
schnell werden diese grafen dann
ziemlich komplex nicht so komplex wie
unser universum offensichtlich aber
durchblicken würde ich da trotzdem nicht
mehr
wenn das ergebnis nicht so aussieht wie
unser universum dann passen sie die
regel an oder probieren einfach die
nächste regel und hoffen dass diese
bessere ergebnisse liefert wenn ihr euch
nicht so ganz vorstellen könnt wie ein
paar einfache regeln zu so etwas
komplexes wie unserem universum zu
schwarzen löchern menschen und
schlussendlich auch zu reality tv bagels
und giraffen führen können
dann empfehle ich euch dieses video hier
von mir ist schon ein bisschen älter
aber es tatsächlich eine meiner
lieblings folgen doktor watson immer
noch nach all diesen jahren die idee von
stephen wolfram ist auf jeden fall ein
völlig neues forschungs paradigma mit
gewaltigen rechenleistungen soll
experimentiert werden um problemlösungen
zu finden so wolfram theorien beweise
und erklärungen seien dann überflüssig
da sie zu aufwendig sein und bestenfalls
nur das bestätigen was man sowieso schon
beobachtet hat das ist das gegenteil von
dem wie die physik seit jahrhunderten
arbeitet und funktioniert
einige aspekte der quantenphysik und der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie sind
wohl tatsächlich schon zufällig bei den
simulationen herausgekommen sagen
zumindest wolfram und seine mitstreiter
kein wunder dass die physik gemeinde das
beschäftigt das ganze erinnert mich so
ein bisschen an per anhalter durch die
galaxis wo ein computer den sinn des
lebens berechnen soll und am ende kommen
nur die zahl 42 heraus was das wiederum
bedeutet weiß keiner
hoffen wir mal dass bei wolframs projekt
etwas sinnvolleres als nur eine zahl
herauskommt wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
dabei sogar helfen auf der webseite des
wolfram physics project finden sich über
800 seiten und 400 stunden videomaterial
die jeden dazu einladen mit zu forschen
ich hab's euch mal unten verlinkt sollte
man sich auf jeden fall mal anschauen
es klingt auf jeden fall alles ganz
schön verrückt aber verrückte ideen
haben sich ja durchaus schon mal als
richtig erwiesen
aus der physik gemeinde hagelte es
jedoch kritik berühmte forschende wie
freeman dyson zum beispiel sagen das sei
alles quatsch
für ihn gehört wolfram zu der sorte
wissenschaftler die im hohen alter
plötzlich große unwahrscheinliche
theorien entdecken andere physiker wie
in erfurt ein ex kollege von stephen
hawking findet die idee immerhin
faszinierend aktuell könnten bisherige
theorien die welt aber auf jeden fall
besser erklären als die modelle von
wolfram manche forschende argumentieren
sogar dass die idee gar nicht so neu
wäre und große informatiker wie alan
turing diese möglichkeiten bereits
gesehen hätten
doch es gibt auch physikerinnen und
physiker die glauben dass an der neuen
herangehensweise etwas dran sein könnte
andrew strohmenger ist physik professor
an der harvard university und
beispielsweise der ansicht dass die
physik dringend neue ansätze und
werkzeuge braucht um die großen probleme
der physik anzugehen
wolfram könnte so einen ansatz haben
denkt er und selbst wolframs kritiker
finden es zumindest interessant das
simple algorithmen komplexe phänomene
wie die spezielle und generelle
relativität reproduzieren können die
spekulation gibt es schon dass wir
irgendwann
ist das menschliche hirn zu beschränkt
und diese sofort zu treiben und dann
muss man halt einen computer nehmen mit
dem alter daten einspeisen und dann sagt
man computer jetzt sucht duman dach der
richtigen form ich will nicht
ausschließen dass das funktioniert aber
ich bin selbst skeptisch dass das
funktionieren kann
weil die frage ist ob der computer ist
sonst eher sagen dem quantensprung in
einzig verführen kann was computer ist
sehr gut können sind extrem komplexe
algorithmen auszuführen aber die
algorithmen selbst bestehen immer aus
der elementaren einfachen strecken aber
die frage ist kann der computer sicher
was ganz neues ausdenken
neu sind computer als hilfsmittel in der
physik auf jeden fall nicht in der
vergangenheit haben sie die forschung
bereits deutlich weiter nach vorne
gebracht besonders bei komplexen
modellen machen sie rechnungen möglich
die früher quasi um lösbar gewesen wären
mittlerweile gibt es auch viele projekte
die versuchen physik probleme mit
machine learning zu lösen
doch auch da hakt es noch an manchen
stellen
[Musik]
ok fest steht wolfram ist von der
wissenschaftlichen community losgelöst
und seine ideen durchlaufen nicht die
üblichen qualitätskontrollen wie prepaid
oder peer reviews von kollegen
stattdessen tritt er direkt an die
presse was mache ich aber besonders
kritisieren
es helfe nicht eine theorie zu finden
ohne sie am ende auch erklären zu können
und da schließe ich mich ehrlich gesagt
an
es hilft auch deutlich weniger nur
voraus berechnen zu können wo viele
straftaten begangen werden um
kriminalität langfristig zu reduzieren
müssen wir auch die zugrunde liegenden
sozialen und politischen ursachen kennen
genau diese kausalität könnten computer
jedoch nicht liefern meint klaus mainzer
physiker mathematiker und philosoph
laut ihm würde uns wolframs arbeit also
nicht weiter helfen selbst wenn er
erfolg hätte ist die idee von stephen
wolfram also genial oder völlig verrückt
was denkt ihr schreibt mir gerne mal in
die kommentare
und was würdet ihr wetten wie viele
jahre wird es noch dauern bis wir die
weltformel finden und dem alten also
gott auf die schliche kommen wie ein
stein es gesagt hat wenn es etwas neues
gibt dann erfahrt ihr auf jeden fall
hier auf doktor watson also vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren und die
glocke zu aktivieren damit ihr das nicht
verpasst und hoffentlich sehen wir uns
schon etwas früher wieder bis dahin
bleibt auf jeden fall neugierig patrick
mitglieder wenn ich die weltformel
gefunden